okay now live chat
right thank you good morning everybody
good morning to any
anyone who's listening on youtube this
is the meeting of the licensing
committee wednesday the 17th of march
um we will go straight into the agenda
apologies please there apologies from
counsellor clark
well that's understandable right minutes
of the last meeting pages three to seven
i'll take take the bottom numbers
they're bigger
so page three page four
page five six
page seven okay page nine
can i have the recommendation or i'll
propose from the chair though
they seem to be the second chair yeah
okay thank you
one two seven
abstain thank
oh it stayed i wasn't there councillor
james
for councillor mckenzie
paul i'm councillor wiseman
oh thank you is now joining the meeting
all right thank you good morning
all right uh moving on the minute was it
was there anything horizon
could i just ask one question please
okay on page seven
bottom um i queried about the um
the feeder taxi right last time and the
signage has been any movement on that
yeah i've spoken to my manager
um janet williams and there's been a few
issues with the harbour
and the property services regarding to
the lining
and the condition of the key needs
resurfacing before they can let people
use it so there is
that's and obviously with a coverage
outbreak as well there's been a delay
because of that but she's now gonna
progress
that um with the relevant people the
harbour and the
um the property services team who are
responsible for the lining and the
the repair works to the key so there is
a delay
um but there is there will be additional
costings now as well so that needs to be
costed out
um before it proceeds
so um not not a satisfactory answer i
would say
i was trying to think how to word it
does um it just seems to me
more delaying tactics yeah i'll feed
that back i'll feed that back to my
manager
thank you please chris saying that we'd
like
yeah i can get a form or we'll get i can
do up a formal
a formal response to committee um but
we'll do that prior to the next because
it is some time to the you know it's
another six weeks in it to the next
committee so we'll get a response to all
committee members
um as soon as i can thank you
okay thank you um if there's nothing
else i'll move on to three
decorations of interest you all know the
rules by now
um if there's anything you need to
declare please do
so at the start of the item um
agreement with the gender items one and
two there is no
part two so we don't need to vote on
that
urgent matters brought forward by the
chair i have
none um is there anything anybody needs
to raise
i know straight speaking is the chair
but in that case we'll move on to
the review of the taxi policy if you'd
like to
yes following on from our previous
meeting back on the 27th of january
where we approved the
um schedule for review of the policy uh
the first stage of the review was to
undertake an informal um consultation
with the trade
so they could put forward any comments
or any items they wish to consider
this was undertaken during the february
period
unfortunately there was a low response
to the survey um
however the prime area of concern is the
proposed
um requirement for the vehicles with
reduced vehicles emissions
and the financial outlay this will
involve and they particularly
were concerned with this and like the
severe disruption to the trade as a
result of the
pandemic um i had hoped for a bit more
feedback so i
did extend the survey deadline um until
the
the 12th of march in an attempt to get
some more responses
um we did have a few more responses and
they were all along
the same the general same um
same areas and items that we'd already
already discussed
um or already included here in in the
response
um we also took the opportunity to
consult with the climate change working
group
um and they were requested to consider
and propose any measures to put forward
um to ensure our policy aligns with the
the council's carbon reduction plan
plans
they have done that and that's included
in appendix a
um i have spoken to the tax liaison
group we haven't been able to hold a
meeting obviously with the coding
restrictions and
some of them haven't got access to zoom
or or anything like that so i have
spoken to them individually
and they really echoed the concerns of
the trade
in respect of the time scales for
implementation
of any restrictions on on carbon
emissions
and also the the lack of infrastructure
that's currently in place
um so their concerns was and again echo
in
the the worst year they've had sort of
trade in and they're now
having to look at new vehicles and
things um there was also an issue
regarding the safeguarding that they
wanted to raise
um it's not really in line with it
doesn't really affect the policy but
they're expected to um report any issues
but their concerns are obviously they're
in taxis they've got their name badges
displayed
obviously they've got their plates and
everything so they're easily
identifiable
their concern is if they do um
whistleblowing effect on people there
will be repercussions to them
um obviously we need to have a look at
that
um but the police maintain
confidentiality there's confidential
hotlines and things you can call um to
report issues
so i think they just need a bit of
reassurance that they
if they do report issues there aren't
going to be repercussions on them
um the only other issue that was raised
was one drive not
in terms of the committee but another
driver raised the dress code
and he did raise concerns that some
drivers are wearing shorts and
and t-shirts so whether that this is an
opportunity to review the
dress code the current code does say
that shorts can be wear but they must be
tailored and must be at least
mid fine length and we do accept
t-shirts but they must obviously not
display any offensive or distasteful
logos or
or designs or slogans or anything like
that so whether we want to consider
reviewing the dress code or when maybe
just a case of we need to do a bit more
enforcement
um on drivers to make sure they are
complying with the existing dress code
so they were the other things raised
during the informal consultation the
next
process is to move on to the formal
review which would commence
on so really now we just need the
committee really to
to decide um i've included an appendix b
the
the um consultation form
so that's whether members want to add
anything else whether they're
happy with what the climate change group
are proposing
and whether they want to make any
amendments to that before we proceed
to the formal consultation process i'll
open
open up now for for any comments okay
doug
doug you've got your hand up do you want
to come up thank you chair um
well i think in view of you know we all
know what a dreadful year has been for
all businesses the taxis have been no
it's no
exception to that they've you know
they've been decimated in terms of the
the money that they could earn so i
would suggest that we suspend
for a period of at least 12 months any
any notions or any
recommendations that we that we put in
print
regarding um changing of vehicles
of any description that includes
electric yes
it would be nice at some point in the
future if
they've all got vehicles that are
cleaner running and less pollutant
um but i think we have to look at the
reality of it
in the in this particular climate you
know it's going to it
it'll take at least 12 months for them
to get anything like back to some kind
of normality so i think it only fair
that we
you know we don't sort of burden them
with any any anything
any additional sort of um cost moving
forward so
i would i would recommend i would
suggest that we suspend anything that we
previously said with regard to uh you
know the
provision of newer vehicles diesel
petrol or
electric okay well we'll come back to
the officer in a minute
about those items now i'm not sure
whether it's chris or doom at first but
chris you want to
you've got your hand up thank you uh
yeah
well several people in the review um
raised concerns about the costs of the
electric cars um
uh if you get a really cheap new
electric car it could be like about 20
grand
ish but i think for a more heavy-duty
vehicle which i expect they would need
they look more like 70. and i was just
thinking should we look at more
given more of an incentive to move
towards electric cars
you know if we're really serious about
climate change maybe we should be given
like 50 percent
discount to the cost of the license and
that as the first year and then
go to 40 then the 30 the year after then
go back to 20
from then on and then also maybe do
something like
a reduced discount for hybrid cars so
there is a slight
benefit but it's not as big as electric
car
this is maybe starting at say 20 but
then dropping down from there
but also i think as part of this we
would need a charge point
on the actual taxi rank which i don't
know so
i guess that would be a devon county
council issue but is that something we
can kind of
push along to make happen because we've
got people getting electric cars and
they can't actually charge them on the
rank
when they're waiting for a job that it
makes sense to
put the two together i don't know what
the logistics of that would be
um and also the i agree with the
comments that some
raised around the safety of wearing
lanyards uh i think that putting on the
dashboard makes much more sense really
from my point you know everyone can see
it when you're in the vehicle
maybe that should be a consideration um
but one other thing is that somebody
raised that maybe a 72-hour notification
period might be better
but i was wondering if there is
something that they need to notify
can they even notify it within 48 hours
if it's on say a weekend
is there someone there so notifying so
it might be more sensible to move to the
72 hour anyway because we couldn't keep
up with it
just in case that scenario did happen
um but yeah oh and also the website
needs updating with the new charges that
cmr put in for taxis
because it's still running by the old
ones of the league
that's different okay okay thank you
chris
denmark
thank you mr chairman uh my apologies
for
um clocking in late this morning um i'd
like to
second council of bushby's i do as a
recommendation or emotion was it uh
council bushby it was okay i'd like the
second council of bushfield on that one
there mr chairman
um obviously given his current year or
previous year even you know
it's being a kick and a tee for most
business owners to be honest any help we
can give them to give a little bit of
grace at the moment to get yourself back
on the feet again as much
needed i think um going forward with
electric cars i mean
you're talking vast sums of money now
when the wages are so low in storage
most normal people aren't going to be
afforded by electric car so
you know whether the authority wants to
be set a president here and actually
buy a few cars for them to trial then i
think that'd be a good way for us to
back up the climate change merchant
we've declared and actually help some of
the traders out
if we're going to do it that way but for
them to put a bid on their own to buy
one of these vehicles
is to me just pie in the sky it's just
it's too much money
all right okay um uh
uh we're dealing with all i'm trying to
make an album we come back to him with
chris in a minute
tony
thank you chair yeah well i i don't know
about um
what counts for bushby um
i i don't know if i agree with that
really because
um for a star it only means that uh
it said it's only from 2022
that all license all vehicles being
licensed for the first time
you've got to meet that criteria not all
vehicles
so so i'll just ask the officer that
that means that just the ones that are
nice the first license they get
first time they get licensed also
i mean we've only got until to do that
we've only got until
april 26 year of 200
2026 to do that so if we put it back for
another year
that means there's only another four
years after that to get that
done and that doesn't seem very long to
me
so i don't know if we have to put it
back now
or no because um i i don't think there's
a need for that at this
at this time thank you chair
thank you council lynch council boy you
want to come back again and then we'll
try and get some answers out of chris
uh marcos yeah um
yeah i'm just gonna go back on um
councilman goff's point
would it be possible for the council to
do a discounted loan for for the tax
drivers to buy
electric cars because i mean obviously
we do it we have done it for other
businesses where they
ask for a big load and we try and do it
at a better rate
is that something that we could do for
them
right i i don't i don't know um right so
it kind of says
it i'm sorry chris all this is going to
get longer
right just as something i'd seek advice
from
stacey first as head of legal um
although
i would support the
intention of what council mcgrath is
saying
i'm concerned that if you favor
one or two or however many businesses
with some form of vehicle it would be
unfair competition on the ones that were
not supported
so i i think something has to be done
across the board or not at all and i've
just seen clarification from stacy on
that
thanks chair
yeah i think there is a potential issue
uh council hackett you're absolutely
right um i suppose it could be a scheme
that's open
to all but that would be something that
would um
need to go to full council for
consideration
um and i suppose it then depends on um
how much you want to offer and and
the terms of the loan etc etc so i think
um it's something that could potentially
be considered but
it would be a policy to bring forward to
full council when it comes to
all right thank you thank you stacey
right
chris um what have we got
okay should i start with the emissions
that's the most sort of controversial
could i just ask um on the climate
change group
um the stuff in dark is that what
they're proposing or is that our
proposal
that's what they're proposing they're
that's what they're proposing
as well at the moment this is only to go
forward for the consultation we're not
actually making a decision today as to
what we're going to implement
this is just what we're going to propose
as part of the consultation
there is obviously as part of the
consultation process
we can get input from other other groups
and and
other counselors and or whatever as part
of that consultation process so we're
not
actually making a decision on the policy
today
[Music]
so looking basically from the first well
if i work down each bit
can i just go back to that minute
question just say in relationship to the
dates they given
how do they fit in with the government
policy dates
the government policy is april i believe
it's april
2030 is when they're
abolishing diesels and petrols or
they're working towards that so
i suppose working backwards on the dates
we've got here from april
2013 all vehicles to be licensed for the
first time must have
co2 emissions less than 50. that's put
that's in line with the government's
expectation or goal um
to to achieve that and that is sort of
nine years time isn't it so
we could keep that one in um the next
one april 2026 again we got five years
there
whatever we decide in this policy isn't
set in stone we can always bring it back
to review if for any reason things don't
move forward as we expect
so possibly the april 2026
could be a realistic realistic goal i
think the main one is the first one
which is from january 2022 all vehicles
licensed for the first time
just to explain basically we we have
sort of three different types of vehicle
applications we've got brand new ones
which are people that are new to the
trade for the first time
we've then got renewals which are those
that exist in
trade are renewing their license every
license lasts for a year so every year
they've got to renew it
and then sometimes vehicles
are renewed by the drivers so there's a
chain what we call a change of vehicle
so that could be within that 12-month
period of their license they could
change to a new vehicle
so what we're looking at here is april
2022 is any new vehicle
license for the first time so anybody
who's existing got an existing vehicle
an existing plate can keep that existing
vehicle
until april 2026
only be if they wish to change that
vehicle in the meantime
then from january 2022 they'd have to
change it to a new vehicle so anybody
who can maintain their vehicle
anybody's got an existing vehicle can
maintain that for another up to five
years
right okay i guess i guess the problem
will arise for the existing trade
is breakdowns for instance if their
vehicle breaks down and it's past
its reasonable full repair
under this scheme then they would have
to buy
an electric vehicle or a euro 6 vehicle
yeah so possibly we could say
that any new vehicle any new people who
are licensing for the first time would
need
euro six but any renewal vehicles
we could possibly do a longer lead in
time for renewal vehicles
um for anybody who has any breakdowns or
change of vehicle
problems with that is getting a bit
complicated then to manage it and
to work out who's doing
what we could put in possibly whether we
put we could extend that january
2022 to january 2023 but review it
in six months or 12 months or
if we propose that it's not set like i
said it's not set in stone we can always
review that and delay it
should the need arise so i think it's
important that we do put
something in place um even it is just
the april 2026
date at least then we've got a got with
goal setting and it gives the trade
something to work towards and they
they do know that they will have to do
it eventually they can begin their
planning
um that's my sort of view
and if we're looking that we've got to
do the further review before we do the
policy we're not going to
get much agreed before january 2022
anyway aren't we
no no we wouldn't anyway i think yeah if
we're not gonna
if we're not happy with that as it is
now i
i i suggest that we do review that date
possibly 2024 or even april 2023 which
will then give us
we could come you know give us 12 months
and come back to
you know a committee in january 2023 as
to whether we
implement that right well that will come
back to the motion
um that dougie and
if you deal with all your queries and
we'll come back to the motion and make a
proposal on it that way
so can you deal with the other queries
grant funding and loans and things i'll
have to do a bit more research on that i
know um authorities that
are bringing in um charging when
um clean air charging which are cities
mainly
they have had government fund government
output funding forward
um so i'm not sure about general
authorities whether there is any
any incentives or anything that we could
put forward
um so i'd have to do a bit more research
on that
go on a forward plan or something sorry
because we put that on the forward plan
for yeah we can put that on the full
plan for the report one way or the other
yeah so we'd look to see what what
funding
and i guess it goes back to what what
stacy answered is whether
yeah whether it's unfair that we're
giving it to taxi drivers not other
businesses or whatever so we would need
to do a bit more research on that
um the percentage
of licensed fees yeah that's
open to debate really i've got i guess
um
yeah there's we can debate on that and
see
um a greater discount
obviously there is implication there
might be implications on us because
the licensing department has to be
self-funding so if we don't get
enough funding we're going to be not
going to have to do everything we should
be doing
um 48 hours
in the 48 hours is what's in the
statutory standards
um so that's what they expect obviously
we don't work weekends so if they were
charged on a friday night we wouldn't
get it to the monday morning
but you know they can email or send in a
note or drop a letter through that
it is within their reams that they could
report it to us
and it's deemed if they've emailed us
then it's deemed as served
within the 48 hours if we get it on a
sunday night and then we pick it up
monday morning
so i'm a bit low to go against the 48
hours as that's what's been put in
in the statutory standards and that's
what the the central government are
expecting us to do
um after check i thought our fees and
charges were correct on the website so
i'll have to double check that
um is there anything else that i've
missed no i don't think so
um probably the ones who raise things
might
say differently so basically we need do
we need to do a motion
um certainly to delay the 2022 one
um or well almost
yeah i think that's the best thing to do
it was proposed and seconded
so should we have a vote that that
although it's only in the review
that we remove that date or we we put on
that date by
at least a year um within the proposed
policy
thing to do doug you're happy with that
sorry ken i was muted um i would be
happy if we just removed that january 22
you know paragraph there yeah i'm quite
happy with the you know from
april 2026 yeah
that's a way off we've got a good lead
in period of that
i think the concern is the is the
the first bullet point yeah so remove
that
i'd be happy then right uh damn what
would you second what doug is just
saying
yes mr chairman still happy to second
that right so if we have a vote then
that that
proposal and it'll be it'll be it's only
a proposal
it's not um we haven't adopted it anyway
but we remove that proposal
from the climate change uh list but
we're happy with the other dates
so yeah have a vote on that please mary
you okay
yes yeah councillor bright
james or council machoff
or council mackenzie
for council wiseman or
your name's chap
so chris is there anything else we need
to do on
the taxi review other than that no
that's it the next stage now will be go
to the formal review
which will go to a wider consultation um
and then it will be reported back to
committee of the forthcoming committee
i think it's eight weeks we propose so
that would be
the first committees of june july time
right okay and there's no hands up we
don't need to go through all the
different responses we've all read them
um do we need to discuss good ones and
bad ones or do we just
accept that we've read them all
so chris is
yeah there's no need no need for any
comments on that unless there's any
objections really or anything that
people want to put into the consultation
as a result of
those comments
we've pretty well covered in one thing i
know nobody else got a hand up
right so we can move on then to
forward plan and obviously what we
had to come up there is obviously the
dress code
um whether we need to look at that again
yeah we would do that as part of the
policy consultation i was thinking
so in the policy consultation um
a report back um about the
signing on the key yeah signage on the
key
um and obviously the
taxi fees right sorry
sorry um yeah the taxi feeder rank of
just making another
yes oh yeah okay um
and obviously um any information you
could glean
on the situation with the
loans or anything to do yeah grant
funding and loans
and loans yeah okay can i make a
suggestion ken that
if chris could informally
asked the the taxi trade um
what the likely take-up would be if such
a scheme
was performed because you know even if
you do that it's still going to be
quite a quite a repayment that the taxi
drivers would
have to have even if they were only
paying back you know 50 percent of it or
whatever it's
going to be um you know a bit of an idea
just to get a get an idea of what the
likely take-up would be if they all
looked up and said i'll forget that
no we couldn't afford that well there's
no point going ahead with anything is
there
no and that was the point i was trying
to raise with the
the climate change ones what um dates
government set dates will fall that will
make
things become an issue legally
in relationship to that so there may be
pressure on them that they've got to go
electric eventually or go clean air
eventually
so i i think there's so no reason why
chris doesn't address that as part of
the
any follow-up to the review we're doing
yeah
are you okay with that chris yes yeah
i'm happy to find out some details and
i'm happy to go back to the trade as
well and
get a you know a straw poll so to speak
as to what what the likely
uptake would be right okay
any other issues we want to put on the
forward pan
just going back to the climate change
again i mean
it's not really i mean the government is
one thing but
you know whether you agree with it or no
torrez has got a policy now that we will
be climate will be carbon neutral
by 2030 yeah
you know so it's it's not all down to
government really we've made that policy
whether you agree with it or no
we've that is the policy that torrance
has got so you know
we have to work to that as well don't we
yeah
well that doesn't mean to say we want
any petrol diesel cars
it's not it's it's not i'm free
no no it's not to say that come that day
there won't be no petrol and diesel cars
it means to say that
um at that date uh there won't be any
detouring
um petrol cars new ones being sold wow
and that's what the government has said
there'll be lots of diesel and petrol
cars going on long long time
after that but it means that torridge
has
signed up to that agreement as well
that's their policy that's our policy
thank you chair
ken you're muted
my sorry my phone is going continuously
so i keep moving it
because my wife's not here so the phone
just rings and rings and then you get a
load message
that distracts you right sorry doug um
you came in a bit then and went out
again but did you know i
i've said my best thank you okay well
obviously
it's all part of the policy review and
we'll
see what the final outcome of that is um
but it's going to be difficult because
obviously then no taxi driver is going
to be looking to spend money
for a while and certainly it's going to
take a while to sort out
how traffic does come back or don't come
back into the town so
at the moment i think what we've got the
recommendations and not starting
too much before 2026 does give people
some sort of guide
right so we're still looking at forward
plan nothing else
nope right well anything from you chris
no that's all from me thank you chair
right
well i think we can wrap up the meeting
um so it's
i thank you and goodbye thank you for
your time this morning you're welcome
ken
i need your job